[Music]
oh yeah that's the game thing that's the
game thing okay cool
uh haters will say isn't gayer big gay
lion with a new episode for us to enjoy
isn't gaiah yes gay lion is like [ __ ]
if if you were having like a like a car
competition and there's like a bunch of
Mustangs and Corvettes and then somebody
pulls up to the lot with a [ __ ]
Ferrari Enzo that's the thing that's
fair did we discuss last time just how
off-kilter all the lettering is on the
wall yes we have did it gets so [ __ ]
it's not even it's like you didn't even
try he got the Letters Out of Michael's
and then he [ __ ] or Hobby Lobby and
then he probably used those [ __ ]
those little uh you know the two-sided
peel off like 3M yeah sticky tabs yeah
who's wearing out on some of them oh
you're right you're leaning a little
they're leaning because this is upside
down no
that is an upside down ass oh my God
you're right
bro
bro okay this guy sucks so much dude can
I say something with how excited you
know it's it's that feeling of like it's
a feeling of like I love covering
Brennan it's super fun making fun of him
he's an idiot but I have been getting so
much more joy covering him like Eve
every time he shows up on screen on
Brennan's show it's everything about
this guy is beautiful he's fantastic
he's a beautiful human being he was the
type of man that has a hobby a [ __ ]
Hobby Lobby credit card and puts the S
upside down he's the best
he's here to dress like a woman and do
terrible rap and he's all out of lyrics
but Casey you you've actually seen it
five times I've seen it five times yeah
if I like something I'll watch it a
bunch it's amazing
just to see somebody like super like
singleness of purpose just like this is
all he's about he's wanting to feel any
sort of anxiety
or empathy or remorse right so those
parts of your brain are and I don't know
if like you know again the difference
being
between a psychopath and a sociopath the
sociopaths are said to be like made by
circumstance hey man listen look I I
also have an audible subscription and I
listen to all these same podcasts you do
repeating [ __ ] NPR podcasts doesn't
make you smart okay I've seen you dress
like a woman and try to be a freestyler
and then try to be a comedian you went
to the San Francisco clown college or
what [ __ ] ever and the San Francisco
clown college entire repair shop and
tire repair shop that's actually
attached to an active Loves Gas Station
they've got an Arby's in there it's
really good it's really good Arby's
unless they're born that's one Theory
but
you can look at somebody's brain and
determine that so I wonder if there must
be an overlap right
um but it's just such an abnormality
that you would be able to Sir can I just
point out something and then another
thing that bothers me about this guy
aesthetically
you can be like a big jacked dude
and then wear clothes that are more
flattering to your form you purposely
wear a size below what you're supposed
to wear on purpose so everyone could see
a [ __ ] jacked you are like you
purposely wear ill-fitting clothing and
it bothers me sir I was like I don't see
[ __ ] Dave Batista good point [ __ ]
red carpet event
bulging out of his [ __ ] dress shirt
like you know what I mean because he
goes to a tailor and they get him a nice
shirt where he still just looks like a
normal human
not only does he buy his size too small
he buys it at Plato's Closet like a
[ __ ] woman yeah he he looks like he
dressed exclusively from Aeropostale he
looks like he dressed himself with the
[ __ ] dressing room Brad Pitt's
dressing room from [ __ ] Interview
with a Vampire you're right it's a
really good point you should have a
point this guy's definitely ripped
multiple pairs of pants and shirts in
the crotch and armpit areas because he
refuses to wear [ __ ] that fits
look man it's good to get shot all right
I guess I just burst out of my clothes
you wouldn't if you bite a size larger I
just can't find clothes that can contain
all my muscles yeah like Dave Batista
can find clothes sorry the rock can find
clothes good point not have you ever
hold on hold on hold on the Big Show can
find clothes
that's probably very difficult
I'm sure he has to make I'm sure Big
Show Paul White probably has to make a
lot of phone calls and stuff to get
shoes it's got to be a pain in the ass
like he can't even just go on Amazon and
scoop up a pair of running shoes it's
like can you call a guy I'm a size 28th
he looks like he's going dressed as
Fabio at a Halloween party yes
because that's a Fabio shirt you know
[ __ ] Van Helsing looking ass
[Laughter]
pull your crossbow where you from
he's supposed to looks like he's a
member of the Dawn Guard [ __ ] [ __ ]
arms look like shrink wrapped Ballpark
Franks
oh they do all right are his arms kosher
this is
the [ __ ] living Stretch Armstrong
looking ass oh [ __ ] he really
Jesus Christ bro you are a weird looking
dude you you know that right like you
tried so hard to be a good looking dude
that you burst past good looking and
then just went into like you look like a
cartoon character you really do you look
like a big gay lion to be honest you
remember Ulfric Stormcloak when you were
a kid well this is him now feel old yet
this is the all fruit storm cloak after
a few years of running [ __ ] Skyrim
being like man I'm just old and tired
did you walk into a store and go yeah
I'd like one shirt torso large arm small
this is all for storm clock he conquered
the Empire and destroyed all the haters
he looks like he's about he looks he
looks like he's about to assemble the
other ThunderCats
[Laughter]
that sucks
you big gay lion get out of here
paralyzed with fear so I guess that's
why he's the only person doing it or if
you put you know if you were to look at
like Elite stunt men or I don't know
Casey Garrity like what you know like
you're right on his back and
never-ending story oh he does he looks
like the flying dog falcore he looks
like Falcons
oh God
that should be also the name of his show
the never-ending story because he just
babbles on and on and on
there must be something
I need a Photoshop of him as Falcor and
Brendan Schwab is one of the rock biters
I like that I like that
a degree to which you can train that
like when Hoff you know the guy who does
all the ice water stuff like that you
see how you know hey you think we know
all the all your little inside La
baseball [ __ ] buddy I don't [ __ ]
care honestly I mean you haven't said
anything that matters we could we could
do 20 minutes just in the way you look
honestly
trt oh this is a segment called Saucy or
not okay you ready
here you go here you go Saucy or not
previously
um I actually thought about yes yes Mark
Wahlberg is on steroids I'm sorry do you
really have to ask this guy that do you
have eyeballs he's 51 to look like that
you're on steroids that's how it works
how
my operating assumption was that he was
on steroids for example in the movie uh
pain or gain he looks bigger like some
rupture in his abs but sometimes you'll
see guys especially Pacific Islanders
not to be racist but their AB insertions
are slightly different you spend a lot
of time studying the male anatomy
seriously dude it's kind of weird man
just
um so let me let me tell you this people
always make this criticism oh yeah
you're promoting The ancestral living
but our early ancestors live to 30. all
right this is what people say all the
time stupid [ __ ] like this right and
here's the fact is you call what we're
doing today living you call going to a
job that you hate comparative measures
and just being living a healthier life
up to that point right and as you said
with acute medicine like penicillin like
you know you're in an emergency great
but it's this message of like you know
instead of
painkillers instead of the things that
we take like okay he's talking a lot
how's this how did this September 2nd
was put up 2644 views
287 now downvotes
this is thick Boy network
yes
this is this is
you know what the issue is okay can I
show you just the related videos is us
making fun of him just to show you if
you type him in we're his algorithm
yeah we are his algorithm that's us
every time we put a video up of him
oh hey look at that look thick Boy
network
all thick Point network is is the king
and the sting
um
was big gay lion
and
um
that's it
it's quite a network the head kick heard
around the world okay Jesus Christ
Brennan
with three C's though so it's legally
distinguishable yeah so it's not you
know it's not the thing that uh Tom
Segura came up with no no